(exciting music)
- Did you know Winnie the Pooh is a girl?
- I did hear about that, yes.
- Do you think it's bullshit?
- No.
- She's kinda got a voice that like,
"Oh, I'd love some honey!"
(laughs)
Yeah, that's spot-on.
- I thought Winnie the
Pooh was in the room.
- No, that's not true.
- How is that not true, you
just keep saying it's not true.
- That would change everything.
- Who thinks that hard about a bear?
- Now she's Canadian?
(laughter)
(elevator music)
(bell dings)
- All right, here are the facts.
Winnipeg, the historical
bear, female and Canadian.
Winnie the Pooh, fictional
character, and he's a boy.
But does it really matter? Nah.
Let's go do another couple characters,
boy or girl, Rabbit?
- Definitely a boy.
- Piglet.
- Ooh, that's a tough one.
- [Cameraman] Is it?
- [Guy at Computer] A boy?
- (laughs) Why?
- 'Cause Piglet's a boy?
I don't know, 'cause of that voice?